In late last year, I started
watching a YouTube channel called Playing
with Power MTG. It’s primarily a cEDH channel,
short for competitive EDH, and though I hadn’t
played high power EDH much at all, let alone
playing competitively, the spectacle of it all,
along with the quality of the editing and the
voiceover, kept me watching. The first 5 or so
games I watched were really cool, you know, seeing
all these expensive cards I’d never played with,
these cutthroat plays, these hyper-optimized
decks. But then gradually I started to notice
something. It seemed like all of the cards were
the same, like the ways decks gain mana are the
same and the ways they draw cards are the same
and the ways they end the game are the same
and the ways they stop other people from ending
the game are also the same. This intrigued me,
and with this observation I did what any normal
person would do—I looked up the top 10 cEDH decks
and a popular decklist for each and compared the
lists to find out how many cards they shared.
All told, there were 20 cards shared by all
ten decks, with nine of these being lands,
five being mana rocks, four being counterspells,
and two being card draw enchantments. There are
also a number of cards shared by all
decks that play a particular color,
such as Dockside Extortionist, Silence,
and Demonic Tutor. Most interesting of all
were the wincons, with the two dominant ones
being Thassa’s Oracle-Demonic Consultation,
run in 7 of the 10 decks, and Underworld
Breach-Brain Freeze-Lion’s Eye Diamond,
run in 6 of the 10 decks. Only two decks
ran neither of these, those being Kinnan,
which generally wins through an infinite mana
combo followed by playing out its entire library,
and Sisay, which generally wins through a family
of flicker-based combos that it can tutor out with
its commander. With this exercise out of the way,
I had established that, yes, there is quite a lot
of card overlap in cEDH. But why is this, exactly?
And what effects does it have on the format?
The first reason that there’s so much overlap
is simple—at a competitive level, players want
to run cards that are as fast, as flexible, and
as efficient as possible. When you’re playing
a chance-based card game, where you might have
access to only a small portion of your deck at a
time, every draw needs to do as much as possible.
This is also the case for other competitive Magic:
the Gathering formats, but EDH is different
from Modern or Legacy in that it’s 100 cards
and singleton. This means that, for a given
type of card, you need to play a lot more
different copies of that type of card than in a
60 card format. If we look at Modern Murktide,
it’s running 9ish counterspells in the
mainboard—the MTGGoldfish list contains
4 copies of Counterspell, 2 copies of Spell
Pierce, and a single copy each of Spell Snare,
Stern Scolding, and Subtlety. A similarly
interactive cEDH deck will often end up running
12 or more differently-named counterspells.
While there will usually be a shortlist of
potential meta pivots in a format like modern
or legacy, in cEDH you’re already playing the
maximum allowed number of your 7th, 8th, and
9th favorite counterspells, because you have to.
This effect applies to most other areas
too—particularly ramp, draw, and win conditions.
Ramp is the most homogenous—fast rocks, rituals,
1 mana dorks, and lands that tap for multiple mana
are king here, though decks usually want rocks
badly enough to run a couple two mana rocks
as well. Draw usually ends up being things that
abuse either the multiplayer aspect of EDH or the
40 life aspect—Rhystic Study, Mystic Remora, and
Esper Sentinel are ubiquitous, and Ad Nauseam is
so powerful that it blurs the line between draw
spell and one-card wincon. Speaking of wincons,
these tend to be overwhelmingly combo based.
Underworld Breach and Thassa’s Oracle-based
combos tend to be by far the strongest available
due to their low investment and resiliency,
and most cEDH decks contain either one of
these or a combo directly tied to their
commander in some way. This doesn’t necessarily
mean that cEDH decks are boring in how they win,
but it does mean that when you look at somebody’s
commander and the colors they’re playing,
you’ll often be able to immediately guess
one or more of their win conditions.
In addition to the previously mentioned reasons,
a big contributing factor to why there’s so much
card overlap between different decks can be
seen right at the outset of looking at the top
10 decks—these decks run a lot of colors. There
are three five color decks, two four color decks,
four three color decks, and a single two color
deck. Fundamentally, this comes down to the fact
cEDH is an essentially budgetless format, which
allows for very good manabases at very little
gameplay expense to the player, barring nonbasic
hate. This, paired with the singleton nature of
the format reducing the number of efficient
options in each color, means that decks will
generally want as many colors as possible, and
only choose to run fewer when there’s a great
card in the command zone to make up for that
loss in efficiency. This can be seen in all of
the partner commander pairings that people go
with—are Vial Smasher the Fierce and Tana, the
Bloodsower insanely powerful cards? No, they’re
pretty mediocre—the reason they’re popular is that
they let a player run a commander they actively
like such as Tymna or Malcolm and add to it a
couple colors they want to have, plus the utility
of having an extra playable card in a pinch.
The result of this is that a lot of meta decks end
up being 4-5 color piles of the best cards in the
format. These decks can be quite interesting
on their own, mind you, as decks with quality
synergies and flexible play paths that better use
these premium cards will outperform decks whose
construction could be described as a jumbled
mishmash of assorted and sundry good stuff.
But the difference between those two decks can
come down to a small handful of cards that the
deck then tutors for, rendering these differences
subtle on the scale of a decklist. In addition,
the realm of what’s possible is limited by
the sheer speed, flexibility, and efficiency
required by the format. Value engines and
wincons must be some combination of fast,
explosive, consistent, resilient, and compact,
and if a deck’s gameplan doesn’t satisfy enough
of these conditions, the deck likely won’t
be able to keep up and pull off wins. This,
to me, might be the biggest issue as you climb
to the highest power levels of EDH—the range
of possible decks you can build and plays
you can make contracts further and further.
It’s at this point that I can hear some of you
saying “who does this casual EDH youtuber think
he is to complain about cEDH?” Or maybe you
were saying that earlier when I was talking
about comparing the top 10 decks. Or maybe
when you saw the thumbnail before clicking
on the video. Regardless, I hear you, and you
know what? I asked myself the same thing while
brainstorming for this video. So I downloaded
Cockatrice and played a bunch of cEDH games.
And between bullying strangers on the internet
with Winota and conversations I’ve had with
various people who play cEDH, several things
about the format beyond the decks themselves
have become clear to me, and a lot of them
are actually pretty interesting. First of all,
there’s generally no rule 0 conversation, because
the whole idea is to be as powerful as possible
within the confines of the EDH format. This
is nice in itself, as a big challenge I’ve
had in casual EDH is the pre-game struggle of
putting together a game that’s actually fun for
everybody at the table. An extension of this
is that there’s not much salt at cEDH tables
compared to casual—the whole idea of the format is
that everything is on the table, so when somebody
rushes a combo or staxes the table into oblivion,
nobody gets particularly bothered about it,
other than maybe about the fact that they weren’t
able to stop it. The social aspects that make
casual EDH fun to me are still present—threat
analysis, table coordination against a scary foe,
trying to curry favor with a potential ally—but a
lot of the more negative social aspects, ones that
come from the friction of players having different
play styles and objectives, are eliminated.
In addition, another cool thing about the
culture of cEDH is the proxy question,
in the sense that it’s basically a solved
issue. The goal of the format is to play
as powerfully as possible, so the community
is generally very proxy friendly, and some
circles are proxy-friendly to the point where not
choosing to proxy fast mana or dual lands that
would make your deck better is considered kinda
weird. This stands in contrast to casual EDH,
where on the one hand you’ll encounter people who
get offended by the whole idea of proxying, and
on the other hand you’ll get awkward situations
where somebody proxies a bunch of power cards
for their janky midrange deck in order to crush
the janky midrange decks of their friends. Having
this issue solved so gracefully in cEDH, with
the answer arising naturally from the format’s
culture of everybody getting the chance to play
EDH as powerfully as they possibly can, is nice.
With all this context in mind, I think
it’s worth going back to reexamine the
premise of this video. I started this video
with an analysis of the top 10 cEDH decks,
and I think it’s important to talk about where
that list came from—EDH Top 16 compiles cEDH
tournament data and ranks decks according
to number of top 16 placements. These are
the decks that consistently show up and place
highly at tournaments, and on a macro scale they
do represent the format on some level. But
the tournaments these decks are pulled from
aren’t just these 10 decks mashing against each
other in pod after pod, and beneath the surface
there’s actually a lot of really interesting
stuff happening here. I’m pretty unqualified
to talk about those things as somebody whose
cEDH career spans a dozen or so Cockatrice
games with random people on the internet, so
I’m going to pull in somebody who is qualified.
[Start The Trinket Mage Section]
Hi, I’m the trinket mage and I have been
playing in cEDH tournaments since 2016.
Alex is 100% correct those top 10 decks are
the most common builds you will see but,
there is something to be said about playing off
meta builds. I’ve exclusively been playing Jace
Vryn’s Prodigy at tournaments since 2016. I
just love manual storm! On paper mono blue
seems un-optimal due to the lack of options.
But my list for example does not run thassa’s
oracle so I am able to win through hate like
hushbringer or torpor orb that people commonly
play against oracle decks. And since nobody
plays jace with any regularity when I go to
a new store or play at a magic fest nobody
knows what my wincons are or how my combos
work! I’ve won plenty of games simply because
my opponent's lacked matchup knowledge. Plus
your pet deck can also be tuned to be more
effective in your personal local meta. For
me I recently included wipe away so I can
forcefully remove permanents without having
to worry about countermagic since my local meta
is more blue farm heavy than most! So don’t be
afraid to try some lower tier cEDH decks! You can
still get great results from an off meta build!
[End The Trinket Mage section]
As the Trinket Mage’s choice
to run Wipe Away suggests,
interaction suites can be a real divergence
point in card choice. In addition,
there are different decks that will thrive in
different metas—some decks are better against
decks which execute their gameplan as quickly
as possible, some decks are better against
slower decks which try to be flexible and
grind value, and others are better against
stax-heavy decks. Depending on the composition
of decks played at a given place at a given time,
it can be highly effective to run decks that
wouldn’t normally be considered top contenders.
As a final point in this section, I think
it’s interesting to think about some of the
weirder implications of the cEDH meta,
ones that specifically derive from the
predictability of top decks. Praetor’s Grasp
is a card commonly played in Ad Nauseam decks,
because as long as there’s at least one similar
deck at the table, it’s effectively a Grim Tutor
with upside that also pulls a pivotal card
out of an opponent’s deck. Mnemonic Betrayal
is an even more powerful example of this
idea—since decks often share so many cards,
in a lot of games it effectively becomes a
better Yawgmoth’s Will. As a third example,
Ragavan effectively offers a downside-less
Outpost Siege effect. It would suck to exile
a Demonic Consultation or Underworld Breach off
the top of your own library on a turn you’re
not ready to play it, but when it’s your
opponent’s library you’re gambling with,
hitting a card like that is all upside, since
either you can go for the win or you can just let
your opponent’s win outlet go to permanent exile.
You will also see cards that get put in a deck for
one purpose, but a given situation might call for
a different one. Birgi, a great mana generator,
can instead be cast as a draw engine if a
player really needs a way to dig through their
library during a given game, and a famously
spicy part of cEDH is the “forbidden tutor”,
wherein a player uses Demonic Consultation, a
popular combo piece, for its original purpose—as
a highly risky tutor. I find these sorts of cases
really fun, as they turn the ostensibly bland card
diversity of some of cEDH’s top decks on its head,
inventing new use cases for existing staples.
This video has been a bit of a journey, because
painting a picture of a whole format is an
inherently challenging thing. I’d encourage
anybody who is interested to give cEDH a try,
since it’s a pretty unique MTG experience. It’s
also just about as proxy-friendly as EDH gets,
especially if you use a program like Cockatrice
where not owning the cards is already built in. My
feelings about cEDH are mixed, because as a format
it has some pretty cool attributes—individual
decks are stuffed with interesting plays and
synergies, and often represent the pinnacle of
a given archetype. Games are fast-paced, complex,
and exciting, with battles for the stack often
containing 5 or more spells and abilities. And
yet, there is a sort of cookie-cutter blandness
when it comes to card diversity, and more
interesting options for draw, mana generation,
and closing out the game will often simply lack
the raw efficiency to be fully viable. For these
reasons, among others, I personally don’t
enjoy cEDH as much as casual, but I think an
understanding of the cEDH format can give a lot of
insights for how to have more fun playing casual.
As far as deckbuilding goes, I think an idea a
lot of people take from cEDH is that playing the
best combos will make your deck better, and while
this is true in the sense that it might make you
win more games, it’s not a useful fact for having
fun with casual EDH unless you like those combos,
like actually like them beyond the novelty value,
and unless you can find opponents who enjoy
playing at a table with those combos. cEDH decks
have gameplans that they’re looking to follow, but
a decent portion of games end with a combo pushed
through either earlier than people can interact or
at an opportune moment when the table is depleted
of resources to respond with. This is not to say
that this is a bad dynamic, and indeed it invites
lots of interesting strategic gameplay and
deckbuilding choices, but these choices
naturally come down to how to win a competitive
game of Magic: the Gathering more so than how to
optimize a “gameplan” in the traditional sense,
and I’d wager that following a cohesive gameplan
to its conclusion is what a lot of people find fun
about casual commander. To me, the more applicable
lesson to be taken from cEDH is the card quality
filter—running cards that are more flexible and
more efficient, cards that consistently feel
at least decent to draw, will improve your deck.
Basically, minimize dead draws, and if cards rely
on other cards to be good, their effect needs to
be very strong to make up for the amount of time
they’ll sit dead in hand. What an efficient
or flexible card means will differ from deck
to deck, but prioritizing these things will
improve your deck’s overall functionality.
Finally, I think cEDH can also serve
as a lesson for why casual EDH can be
difficult to have fun playing sometimes.
cEDH games are generally friendlier and
less salty than casual EDH games in large part
because player expectations are aligned from
the outset of the game in the sense that
everybody is there to win at all costs,
and deck power levels are affixed at the
most concrete value: as high as possible.
This is certainly not to say that playing at that
power level is the way to have fun playing EDH,
but it is to say that aligning expectations
and power levels before the game is a step
that exists in casual EDH, an unsolved problem
that is presented anytime four people walk up
to a table to play a game of commander. EDH
is a social game, and the way to have more
fun is by talking to your opponents more, both
during the game and before the game even starts.
Thanks for watching! And big shoutout to the
Trinket Mage for helping with this video,
a link to his channel is in the description
if you wanna go check his stuff out. I also
have an announcement, which is that
the Patron deck I randomly selected
to be reviewed next week is Gruul Control. So
that should be cool and fun. Alright, bye now.